oui alors les énergies renouvelables
j'ai pas ggg j'ai été un peu taquin sur
les sur sur une chose mais qui
correspond encore une fois ou fait je
vais vous donner un exemple à la suite
du grenelle on aurait dit le truc
intéressant s'est déployée les poêles à
bois
j'aurais dit très bien on a dit on va
investir dans les panneaux solaires
photovoltaïques
c'est la dernière des conneries qu'il
fallait faire donc je suis pas contre
les énergies renouvelables je suis
contre la méthode sentimentale de
gestion d'un sujet sérieux
à partir du moment où le sujet est
majeur on ne gère pas que des méthodes
sentimental moi si j'ai un sujet majeur
dans ma boîte je vais jamais gérer ça
avec des méthodes sentimentale sinon je
suis sûr de couler il ya un pays qui est
remarquable en matière d'énergies
renouvelables qui s'appelle la suède la
suède n'a quasiment pas de combustibles
fossiles dans son industrie lourde
quasiment pas je vous rappelle soit dit
en passant que la suède consomme autant
d'électricité nucléaire par personne que
la france vous le saviez ça autant
la france en suède
et ils ont sauf erreur de ma part une
réputation parfaitement écolo musiciens
donc la suède consomment deux fois plus
d'électricité que la france par personne
moitié hydraulique moitié du clae r
l'industrie lourde utilise
essentiellement de l'électricité
décarbonés et du bois ils ont ils ont
une consommation de gaz et de charbon en
suède qui est quasi nulle et la totalité
du chauffage est assuré avec des réseaux
de chaleur au bois mais ils ont trois
cent cinquante mille kilomètres carrés
de pays pour 9 millions d'habitants
couvert à 70 % de forêts et et est la
clé du succès pour les énergies
renouvelables
elle va être là toujours la clé du
succès pour les énergies renouvelables
c'est beaucoup de montagne beaucoup d
espace pour faire pousser quelque chose
sinon compliqué une des énergies
renouvelables à mon avis très
intéressantes à regarder pour les
européens c'est ce qui se passe dans le
désert où il ya plein de soleil et pas
beaucoup de monde à emmerder et au lieu
de dépenser 100 ou 150 milliards d'euros
dans la cspe pour déployer du
photovoltaïque en france on aurait fait
un grand projet industriel avec ça pour
se mettre d'accord avec les marocains
les algériens ont du gaz qui s'en
foutent et les tunisiens et les libyens
aujourd'hui on aurait pris pied sur
quelque chose où on était sûr de donner
du boulot aux ouvriers français pour
développer des technologies qui seront
peut-être extrêmement utile dans tout
l'est dans toute la bande tropicale à
l'avenir donc voilà je suis pas du tout
contre les énergies renouvelables je
suis un grand partisan des énergies
renouvelables gérer avec des méthodes
sérieuse
je suis désolé c'est beaucoup plus
sérieux que le [ __ ] 1 liberté qui serait
beaucoup plus sérieux que desertec vient
écouter les espagnols aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont en train de trouver la potion
économique pas très sympathiques ils ont
plein de soleil dans le sud est à mon
avis allait faire des choses
intelligentes dans le solaire à
concentration avec les espagnols
aujourd'hui c'est bien mieux que de
faire du pays en france voilà du
photovoltaïque en france
voilà donc la question c'est par dont
l'éolien en france n'a pas beaucoup
d'intérêt
l'éolien a de l'intérêt dans les pays
qui ont des centrales à charbon qui
souhaitent consommer un peu moins de
charbon si vous commencez à avoir une
diffusion massive de l'éolien vous avez
besoin de moyens de stockage derrière et
là le coût du mégawattheure éolien
stocker restituer dans une steppe que
vous auriez créé pour l'occasion ils se
baladent quelque part entre 200 et 400
euros
alors ce n'est pas nécessairement une
mauvaise chose parce que contrairement à
ce que vous pouvez penser une hausse du
prix de l'énergie moi je m'en fous si
c'est de l'art entre distribué
nationalement
d'accord je m'en fous ce qui non mais
c'est ça qu'il faut que ce soit alors
par ailleurs un autre truc j'ai pas le
temps de vous présenter aujourd'hui mais
notre évêque de troyes qui se trouve sur
mon site montre et ça c'est peut-être le
mot de la fin que quand vous déplacer
une énergie produite nationalement
exemple nucléaire vers une autre énergie
produite nationalement exemple l'éolien
si vous payez les gens la même chose
dans les deux cas de figure globalement
nous ne crée pas d'emplois c'est
perturbant mais il ya une règle de droit
qui permet de le montrer